là où ça va pas c'est la dissolution des
bacs mais je crois qu'il sait pas ce que
c'est une bague en fait monsieur maison
alors expliquez lui je lui ai gagné
parce que je crois qu'il n'a pas bien
compris le fonctionnement des baquets
moi je suis dans back depuis depuis cinq
ans et ça fait 20 ans que j'exerce en
seine-saint-denis sur la voie publique
je vais pas cacher un bureau je suis sur
la voie publique ça j'ai travaillé cette
nuit mais deux dernières interventions
en tant que bas que ça a été d'aller au
secours de deux femmes qui se faisait
battre par leurs maris à 3 heures du
matin c'était ça la table sur le papier
ça la bac c'est pas autre chose c'est
pas votre vos caricatures et vos
amalgames que vous dénoncez d'ailleurs
quand on parle de communauté musulmane
mais vous avez raison vous faites la
même chose avec la police nationale et
ses fonctionnaires exactement la même
chose pareille la bague c'est pas moi je
ne drague pas matin au boulot en me
disant je vais bien chauffé un gamin de
15 ans lui bourrer un peu la tronche
depuis le pic et sa barrette de shit ou
crois que c'est ça mon délire ou crois
que je jouis de faire ça moi arrêter
c'est une caricature ridicule en plus et
c'est irresponsable pourquoi moi je suis
sur une circonscription de 60000
habitants la nuit il ya deux véhicules
la police secours et la bac la police y
ont cours à l'est toujours engagé à des
déplacements elle est allée jamais
disponible il reste que les bacs vous
voulez retirer qui valait sur les
missions d'urgence qui va les porter
assistance aux gamins qui se fait
racketter au lycée qui va les défendre
la femme qui se fait battre par son mari
la nuit qui va faire ça je vous pose la
question vous vous donnez des ccd ddc de
la politique politicienne pur et dur
savard a collé les personnes antipolis
très bien si c'est votre électorat il
n'y a pas de problème il ya 73 % de la
population qui adore sa police qui aime
sa police donc de dire que la police
assassinent tous ces slogans qu'on ait
des barbares qu'on vous a entendu dire
c'est ridicule s'est créé de la haine et
il n'y a aucun intérêt j'ai discuté
avant l'émission avec sofia on s'est
même échangé nos coordonnées on s'est
dit effectivement il faut du rapport du
rapport humain la police de proximité
vous avez raison je suis rentré la
police c'était la police de proximité il
y avait du bon sarkozy est arrivé nous a
retiré tous les effectifs je vous suis
là dessus vous avez raison mais il faut
des forces d'intervention les deux
premiers policiers qui rentrent au
bataclan ce sont deux policiers de la
bac il neutralisa un assaillant et tous
les autres se retourner vers eux ça a
sauvé sûrement des dizaines de vies les
bas que si les policiers de voie
publique les policiers qui interviennent
en prime aux intervenants ils sont nés
c'est plus que nécessaire le sentiment
d'insécurité des français et je voulais
entendu dire ça d'ailleurs c'est pas les
braquages de banques c'est pas les
homicides sait également qu'il va se
faire racketter si la nana qui va se
faire qui va se faire harceler
sexuellement dans le dans le métro c'est
ça et si les baqueux qui vont en premier
ils vont pour effectivement si on fait
interpeller on fera du flagrant délit
nouveau pour rassurer la victime pour
lui expliquer la procédure pénale et
dans quel sens à agir pour la rassurer
c'est ça qu'elle attend des victimes et
si vous voulez dire si vous voulez des
soutes ces bacs on va dans le mur c'est
ce que je voulais devenir instamment
j'allais vers
l'action police est un échec total
ça fait 30 ans que tous les ans une à
deux lois concernant la sécurité sont
adoptées par les gens qui font des
surenchères verbales continuelle
toujours au long des bons sentiments que
nous partageons tous car moi je ne
connais pas une personne dans mon
entourage qui va vous dire que par
principe il n'aime pas la police il
n'aime pas cette police là cette police
violente cette police qu'à éborgné 32
personnes sans qui un seul coupable
cette police qui a tué une femme qui
était au quatrième étage à marseille
cette police qui fait ce qu'elle veut
quand elle veut et quand on pose une
plainte vous retrouverez qui gpn pour
décider ce qu'il faut décider igpn était
composée de policiers il ya donc en
quelque sorte une corporation qui s'auto
contrôler la police est aux ordres de la
nation aux ordres c'est pas elles
coordonnent
et ce genre d'accident activités comme
on en voit sans arrêt est insupportable
il ya 7000 bas que comme vous dites il
ya 5000 policiers seulement dans la
police judiciaire or ce que nous vous
demandons d'abord de régler c'est le
trafic des êtres humains qui s'est
développée au x 4 dans ce pays c'est le
trafic de drogue qui s'est multiplié
dans ce pays c'est la circulation de 6
millions d'armes voilà quoi vous êtes
d'abord responsable est ce que vous
ferez si je suis élu car vous obéirez et
ceux qui parmi vous se sont couverts
d'opprobre ont ridiculisé la police par
des comportements personnels raciste
autres seront expulsés de la police
nationale
couchez
vous m'entendez je crois à la police
qu'un public n est pour qu'il y ait une
police républicaine il faut qu'on cesse
avec les gens qui se comportent comme
vous vous comportez vous vous même
personnellement parfaitement mais votre
histoire on la raconte avec plaisir il
avait blessé un jeune de 16 ans avec un
ciseau vous pouvez mission unique et
comment c'est possible mais c'est pareil
je veux dire aucun problème alors
racontez nous qu'est ce que c'est que
cette affaire jean luc mélenchon c'est
lui qui le raconte au service avec lui
normal haili laquelle j'ai bien sûr
c'est moi l'accusé bages 12 accuse
d'accord bah alors maintenant c'est la
défense
monologue merci à l'essayer donc si
c'est pas si on a contrôlé un jeune d un
groupe d'individus dont est un porteur
d'un ciseau failli se battaient entre en
fait donc il y avait 1 6 o s'est désarmé
de ce jeune avec ce ciseau et lorsque
j'ai attrapé par le cou il a été blessé
il a eu un point de suture il n'a pas
déposé plainte contre moi j'ai appelé
immédiatement je voulais porter un
regard de son père aussi c'était pas
pour ça j'appelais procureur et personne
n'a suivi ce n'est pas du tout été mis
en cause dans cette affaire sinon à
faire mais si je vois la bassesse du
débat ça m'étonne pas ce que j'ai vu que
ça leur faisait bon ballon pour preuve
les bains voit la taille et le mot est
lâché ah oui avec monsieur zemmour
s'était pas un comportement ouais ouais
ouais mon cou pas honoré le vote il est
notre intérêt c'est ce volet envers
galles millennium encore orléans garde à
vue ce sondage suis pas qu'on dit vous
savez oui vous n'êtes pas candidat mais
moi je voulais finir l'épisode suez lui
est venue de l'intérieur a
tenu à éclaircir inquiet les policiers
sont républicains vous vous n'êtes pas
républicain non monsieur moi j'ai perdu
là tous les jours la
palme d or
l'essentiel sèches à yannick vous dites
vous dites que vous oublierez comme les
autres vous et n'oubliez pas ce que je
veux moi je suis république avec jacques
[Applaudissements]
pas laisser dans des unités comme tel
avait laissé faire vous aviez souvent un
oui dans l'unité que vous commandiez
s'étira plage ball sur un jeune de 16
ans personne n'a été puni est ce que
vous dites rendre deux personnes ont été
brûlées jeudi et un policier qu'après un
pavé l'a alors c'est normal il s'est
fait l'arrêt mais voyons tous les
voyants d'un policier catholique
de bernard et le placer parmi la police
de
le répéter